now I just mentioned this disturbing
allegation that Muslim parents and their
children former students who want to opt
out of this sexualized curricula in our
schools are now akin to White
supremacists joining me now is one of
those parents Karim monib he's the
president of Coalition of virtue and
organized a rally over this issue Kareem
you and I were talking before the show
and US Catholics and uh other Christians
other people of Faith have been waiting
for the Muslims to step up on this issue
and so many others and you really are
doing it in your community what is your
response to some of what we just shared
in that angle well first of all I want
to thank all of the Brave heroic parents
that came out to the rally there's a lot
of fear of of standing up as you
mentioned and we want to break through
that wall of fear and want people to get
motivated and powered to just to to
raise their voices for what everybody
recognizes is is reasonable and so I
want to thank those parents if you're
watching the parents of family rights
for Religious Freedom is that's the
local Montgomery County parent group
thank you so much you are brave and and
everybody's watching and your actions
are having an effect and and the young
students who spoke out I was so
impressed with them amazing I mean they
documented and recounted how they've
been bullied for actually saying well
wait I'm a I'm a person of faith I'm not
perfect but I'm a person of faith and
this offends my sensibility uh yet
they're the ones being targeted in the
schools yet they still spoke out that's
right it requires a lot of Bravery one
of the students I recall from their
testimony said isn't that why people
came to this country for Religious
Freedom and and now that's been taken
away from us and he'd mentioned also
that what is the meaning of freedom
freedom is the ability to do what you
want uninhibited and that is clearly not
the case now cream I want to play more
from this Montgomery County uh council
member Kristen mink from yesterday watch
this
the scientific and medical community has
come to a clear consensus that lgbtqia
plus people exist
when we have children's books that
represent uh you know a child who has
you know who is transgender that is the
reality
and so mcps has the responsibility to
include and reflect that reality in our
curriculum
now Kareem this is a school district
that we fought tooth and nail to open up
those schools one of the many left-wing
school districts that that really hurt
kids during this coveted pandemic they
were never held accountable in fact they
re-elected their County Executive Mr
elrich so what do you make of her come
this is all consensus it's already
established it's it's absolutely that's
ridiculous it's not a consensus there's
no scientific consensus that says a boy
can become a girl simply by declaring
something with his with his voice um and
that's it's it's rejected by science
it's rejected by every Faith tradition
and so you know these kinds of arguments
are silly I want to say that what what
Coalition of virtue our vision is to
bring together people of all faiths
which I love and we want to restore the
moral consensus that we had in this
country since its Inception and we want
to bring people of all faiths and even
those who may not belong to any
particular traditionalist perhaps
traditional reasonable people I think
that if we come together we can become a
political critical force in this country
that can save save us from what's
Happening you Kareem and all of those
kids who spoke out and former students
you all petrify the left and so now they
claim that you're the white supremacist
that's how low they have gone but you
don't seem too worried about it it's
absolutely ridiculous assertion I mean
most of the people out there were like
you said brown or black so it's
offensive uh it's only going to um
yeah because more people know what's
going on now Kareem thank you for coming
in and thank you for doing what you're
doing and I'll help you in any way I can
thank
you.org if you want to join us I'm a
warrior for you thank you so much great
to see you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else